hey guys welcome to nerding out the show
where we at GameSpot get our nerds
together and talk about shows that we
like today we're talking about Westworld
episode six the adversary so let's jump
in
okay guys two timelines Ryan what do you
think yeah I think definitely it's two
timelines here Westworld tweeted out on
September 30th in West world even logos
deserve a closer look
so obviously the keys in the logos we
saw in the William and Logan timeline it
is an old-school looking logo we see
this again when Bernard goes down to
basement Neath 87 80 66 and we see him
go down there on the computer that's the
old school logo and then when Maeve is
walking around with Felix yeah it is
that newer refresh redesigned logo so
it's two timelines there's the William
in logo Logan and then there's a current
one where Maeve is all the stuffs happen
with Maeve as well as men and black men
in black so it's finally confirmed I
five yeah that's like our first like
legit piece of edit evidence cuz it was
never really that clear but now they're
like look at the logos logos in the show
previous to this um I don't remember
what episode but we have seen two
different versions of the logo the thing
that I want to point out is that the
maze is is currently being created we
discussed this a little bit earlier play
in which timeline in the earlier
timeline the timeline that has William
and Logan and William is the furqan man
when William and and and Teddy I'm sorry
the man in black and Teddy are looking
for the maze that's that's current
timeline the maze is actually being
created so the whole thing with the
whole thing with Ford and Theresa
happened in it earlier timeline that's
why I think that fortas house
what you said last week and also we have
to address this because we saw Ford's
family right yeah for this house family
family Arnold as most Arnold made Ford's
family is that really for its family or
his Arnold like the creator of Ford and
then did he suffer in the hands of his
own creation I think so when they popped
up on the screen saying though there's
five hosts that are in Sector 17 and
anyways when they go to that next show
of the family there's only four family
members and Ford walks in and I'm like
his dog host five is Ford host bye
Arnold made Ford hat like all the hosts
have memories mm-hmm they have memories
that don't exist right some of them have
like you know implanted memories now I
will say that this can be counted like
countered by like every single memory
that they have is something that
actually wasn't planted like why it
exists but did he ever shoot all those
all those soldiers did that ever happen
probably not so I think that Ford had a
bunch of memories of his family and
Arnold was like you know what I'm gonna
make that family for you you gotta get a
drunk Irish dad it was really rough for
you pal yep so is dog or Ford number
five we don't know that's the mystery
but let's talk about our buddy Arnold so
we've got some Arnold answers this week
finally a little bit of clues here and
there so we have LC discovering this
base where I assume Arnold is talking to
these first-generation hosts it's Arnold
it's gotta be Harold right it's I think
the question is is Arnold an actual
human or is he a program or software
that he's implanted into these house
he's uploads consciousness into a host
thank you and people on the internet
saying it's Bernard I'm not completely
sold on that I think it might be a host
that we haven't seen yet but I think
Arnold is there but it's his
consciousness and host yeah I think that
makes sense and you know we had the
whole theory of the Odom tribe and this
man in the maize horse like hey this is
what this means and everybody that logo
just keeps popping on and and when Ford
saw it he was really surprised he's like
what the heck is this yeah so he goes to
that notebook exactly so like all roads
lead to the maze yeah he's building the
maze it's Arnold's notebook he's just
taking all of his notes and trying to
miss copies I don't think that Ford is
against Darnell Toyotas think that
Ford's against I think the Ford is just
trying to make stuff work what
Arnold want me to do what does my
Creator want me to do because he's a
freaking host yep so else he calls
Bernard and says yeah the person that
accessed this to the host it was Theresa
and he was in the room with Theresa but
he played it super cool he's like I
can't talk about this right now but I
think maybe Theresa is being controlled
so maybe she's also a host is she
working with Arnold or is she working
for
like Dulles like I can't tell but I
think she's a host being under control
and that's why she's talking to these
hosts I know everybody yeah maybe she's
a smoking gun she does smoke puns get
out go that moment where Maeve said to
Felix how do you know that you're real
it gave me the creeps so let's talk
about Maeve a little bit so she's super
intelligent now anyone ever heard that
word bulk yeah yeah yeah intelligence
turn it all the way up so now she's just
gonna be ahead of the humans in terms of
thought in terms of quickness of
thinking so what does that mean for
everyone it's super scary for everyone
else in there I feel like right I mean
who knows what you know with the power
that she has and she's gonna I don't
think you know as they pointed out to
that and what's in your head like for
processing power is now tenfold of what
it was before faster than anyone else in
the room so it's gonna be scary to see
what she used an advantage obviously she
is gonna lead some type of I feel some
type of revolt some kind of revolution
some enlightenment and she did ask for
them to turn her pain down threshold
that could potentially be bad turn it
down everything that's good turn it up
she's not like you let's bump this down
just a little bit like turn that crap
down all the way yeah complete crazy
cyborg that just murders before they
adjusted that they saw that someone was
already messing with her adjustments
someone way above their pay grade so I'm
thinking definitely Arnold right yeah I
don't say 100% Ireland that's also
what's happing to Dolores exactly yeah
those two heard hard singled out as
making the disastrous also something
came to light that the employees are
running a robot whorehouse and that's
gross bad folks not really trustworthy
people you know we just were like oh man
they're running a robot whorehouse she's
the proprietor another point to make is
that um you know there's an interesting
cut after
Maeve's tour of the facilities war was
weird no one was looking when they cut
back to her in the operating room they
it was really weird it was almost like
they never left the room which would
explain why no one was looking at so
weird how easily they were able to get
around I did to Felix shouldn't be
walking around with the hosts I don't
care what if he's the butcher right yeah
yeah look you just the budget it's weird
that he's walking around be walking
around with the hose to where you want
to go and I go to tour of the entire
place let's go stop them know what's up
you could either knock a robot over
throw them in a wheel barrel and run
them up to the design where the designer
wants to see them or you can just press
the button and they walk on the legs
that you made them it is a good feature
yeah
go ahead not a cart like just getting
the feel like getting this car
structured responsibilities though yeah
it's like this right yeah this should be
weird this is a bigwig corporate face up
but design can you bring uh Maeve up
here we want to look at her but just a
glaring writing error like that no one
stopped them I don't know but also it
was kind of just set up so that she can
see her own dream slash memories on that
screen yeah yes I feel like that's what
that setup was and maybe it was just
lazy or maybe they're smarter than us
and they're like no there's something
here yeah but we'll have to see next
week's episode is called trunk Lloyd I
don't know how to pronounce that I'm not
French but it's French for deceive the
eye and it means a visual illusion of
art especially is used to trick the eye
into perceiving a painted detail as a
three-dimensional object I think this is
about Ford's family he's made up
everything is getting the eye at this
point right I mean every literally so
it's like yeah I don't I'm completely
lost in terms of what they could be
particularly interested in here only to
the episodes left only seven so there's
ten there's ten total we're good okay
we're join us next week we'll be talking
about that episode and we'll see you
later thanks for joining us on nerd
hangout